why
so Wolverine vol 3 issue number 44 I
think is going to be a very great comic
for those of you who are avid Wolverine
fans but have really kind of felt
disappointed by the amount of dialog and
Wolverine vol 3 issues number 42 and 43
and the reason for this is because these
comics are really kind of buildups these
comics are really kind of setting this
stage for this ultimate kind of showdown
between Wolverine and nitro but oddly
enough the story doesn't necessarily go
the way that you think it will so what
we see as the story unfolds is that
Wolverine is absolutely pummeling nitro
that he is really kind of expelling all
this revenge that he's been holding on
behalf of the Stamford Connecticut
residents he's really kind of punishing
nitro as best he can and this is really
kind of Wolverine in his element I think
that one of the biggest misconceptions
that a lot of people have who do not
read comic specifically Wolverine comics
is that Wolverine is kind of this
mindless person that Wolverine just kind
of just destroys stuff he does his own
thing with no real regard for anything
that goes on around him and to a degree
that's true depending on which Wolverine
were talking about if we were talking
about Ferrell Wolverine that would be
very much true but Wolverine for the
most part in fact in the majority of the
comics as we see him while he is an
antihero and while he really kind of
walks his own path in the end he's
really kind of a good guy he's really
kind of doing things the best way he
knows how
and in one of the biggest instances when
we saw him recruited into the New
Avengers Wolverine does things that a
lot of other people are just not willing
to do in order to achieve a necessary
result now as the story continues we
actually transition to Janus and the two
individuals unknown individuals that
were with him monitoring the conflict
between Wolverine and nitro now one of
the individuals a woman whom we do not
know is on the phone with a third party
presumably somebody they take direction
from and they're really kind of telling
us that they've established contact with
Wolverine that they have established
contact with nitro but they don't know
who over it is they don't realize that
it's him now they're asked by the person
over the phone if Wolverine or if this
individual is an enemy
our friend now from their perspective
because of what's really kind of going
on there presuming that he is an enemy
because I don't just really they really
don't know him and it's really kind of
the the safest road to take they're
instructed by the individual over the
phone that their priority objective is
to continue trying to capture nitro but
if this third party Wolverine gets in
their way
they have the authority to kill him now
from here we switch back to Wolverine
and nitro and this is an extremely
important part of the comic because this
really kind of gives us again this idea
that there are some major forces at work
when it comes to the Civil War event and
what we really kind of see here is that
nitro is really kind of begging for his
life of course he asked wolf Ryan if
Wolverine intends to kill him and
Wolverine says that of course he does
because nitro really kind of deserves
what he deserves to be killed for what
happened that nitro really kind of
deserves to die in addition we see that
nitro really kind of begins to plead
with Wolverine that he kind of begins to
beg with Wolverine and this is really
kind of interesting here because
Wolverine has enough experience in terms
of interrogation using some less than
savory methods to know that when someone
is aligned that there is a genuine kind
of lying on that they are in fact
actually lying and so Wolverine while
he's really kind of talking to nitro and
while nitro is pleading with him
Wolverines a little bit skeptical here
he's a little bit hesitant and of course
nitro goes as far as to say that there
was somebody else that had a hand in
this somebody else that basically threw
nitro was able to kill 600 people
because nitro never really had that
power before and this is a true
statement there had never really been an
instance in Marvel Comics where we had
seen nitro self detonate on such a scale
that he was able to obliterate a large
portion of a town and kill 600 people at
one point even during the storylines
where he was involved with Captain
Marvel and so because of the fact that
Wolverine is kind of intrigued by this
at the very least this bit of
information he allows nitro to continue
talking and nitro presents to him some
pills and he presents these pills as
something called MGH called mutant
growth hormone and that for normal
people it's basically Hg
age but for mutants it's really kind of
a superpower enhancing thing and this is
the reason why night Rio was able to
self-destruct on such a scale now
initially Wolverine doesn't really care
about this he thinks that nitro is
really just kind of pointing the finger
and saying that yes while I destroyed
Stanford Connecticut I was only able to
do it because somebody gave me drugs and
that's true to a degree but Wolverine is
really kind of focused on wanting to
ensure that the most I guess the
ultimate parties those all individuals
who had a hand in this are punished for
the events in Stamford Connecticut and
he really kind of you know I guess since
out nitro he really kind of smells out
nitro and realizes that you know people
in this kind of position will say pretty
much anything and that those individuals
who were facing death will say virtually
anything to keep from dying but he
doesn't really smell any anything
indicating that nitros died or nachos
lie he doesn't really get any kind of
vibe from nitro indicating that nitro is
not telling the truth here and so he
tells nitro to continue talking but just
as nitro is getting ready to give him
the name of the person that gave him
these pills we see that Wolverine is
attacked by Janus now this is really
kind of an interesting fight because it
actually takes Wolverine off-guard for
the most part not in the sense that not
that Janus appears out of nowhere but
because of the fact that Janus is for
the most part able to go toe-to-toe with
Wolverine and bare-knuckle fist fighting
now again the reason why I say this is
kind of kind of takes Wolverine by
surprise is because very rarely do we
see individuals who were able to take
wolve reign on hand a hand in physical
combat one because Wolverine is a
prodigious fighter he has all sorts of
skills and hand-to-hand combat but to
Wolverine has a healing factor and he
has adamantium and so his physical blows
are absolutely crushing and so most
individuals would be able to go
toe-to-toe with him for a few minutes
but they will be worn down extremely
fast by Wolverine from there we continue
to see the fight go on we continue to
see him see Wolverine and Janus again go
bear to bear and really kind of fight
one another but now they've really kind
of progressed to using weapons where
Wolverine is using his adamantium claws
and Janus is using some kind of knife
like weapon that we've never really seen
before but then we see that this unknown
will
and calls off the fight between the two
individuals and that the male the
unknown male has successfully subdued
nitro now from here we see that this
woman really kind of begins to bargain
with Wolverine and tells Wolverine that
if he leaves if he allows them to take
nitro with them that they will go in
peace and they will have no no more
quarrel with Wolverine but Wolverine is
not willing to accept these terms
because again Wolverine wants to ensure
that all guilty parties regarding
Stamford Connecticut are held
responsible for their actions and so we
see that Janus re-engages Wolverine and
the two of them begin to fight once more
but then we see that nitro attempts to
overpower this individual that we know
as Paul who is really kind of attempting
to keep him subdued and that Paul I'm
sorry that that nitro begins the process
of self-destructing but - Paul shoots
him with something that really kind of
disables his ability to use his powers
from there we again switch back and
forth between Wolverine and Janus as the
two of them are really kind of fighting
the respective enemies we see Janus
fighting Wolverine we see Paul and the
unknown woman attempting to subdue nitro
and then we really kind of switch to
some unknown location and we see the two
individuals presumably working in an
office building are really kind of
talking about severing ties or ensuring
that the ties are severed between
themselves and nitro so that no one can
really kind of trace the connection
between the two of them at this point we
switch back to Wolverine and Janus and
we really kind of get the portion of the
comic that deals most with dialogue
they're really kind of deals more with
giving us information and this is
actually done in a very interesting way
and gets us some really cool information
initially the woman that is talking with
Wolverine that's Wolverine why it is
that he's willing to give his life for
someone like nitro and Wolverine states
that he's not giving his life for nitro
that he's not going to die for nitro but
the nitro basically has information that
he needs in addition we see that nitro
is able to kind of sneak up on Wolverine
and really kind of able to not
necessarily overpower him but really
kind of take him by surprise and of
course we see that Wolverine is in turn
able to overpower nitro and then we kind
of again switched back to the discussion
portion kind of switch
to the dialogue where we see that Janus
attempts to attack Wolverine but
where-when kind of tells him not to that
says that this fight really kind of
needs to stop and everybody needs to
calm down and then he starts talking
with nitro when he asked nitro I'm sorry
he asked Janice how is it that you're
able to go toe-to-toe with me how is it
that you have this much strength is it
because of a strength boost of some kind
mutant growth hormone radiation to the
super-soldier formula and we see that
Janice says that it's their birthright
but they are born with this inherent
ability that they don't come from
Stanford Connecticut they don't come
from anywhere in the world and then we
see Janice really kind of put on an
oxygen mask and inject himself in the
neck and then take on the full
appearance of an Atlantian now from this
point Wolverine really kind of has an
idea of what's going on now though these
Atlanteans are there - I guess procure
nitro for the purpose of nitro standing
trial or the very least facing justice
for his actions in Stanford Connecticut
because his actions resulted in the
death of Naima Rita we learned that Paul
and the unknown woman are members of the
the Atlantean royal family and they've
been sent here to acquire nitro now
Wolverine asks who it was that send them
here and then we switch to name of the
Submariner who says do you even have to
ask that question so the Fantastic Four
issue number 539 is a very important
comic for several reasons the first is
that it really kind of gives us the end
result of the decision that Ben Grimm
makes which side is he going to choose
is you want to choose Captain America
side is he going to choose Iron Man side
because this is an aspect of Ben Grimm
that is really kind of an interesting
throughout the Civil War event he's
really remained neutral and so his
neutral stance will really kind of come
to a head in this particular comic in
addition we're really kind of an
introduced to the I guess the the
desires the kind of goals of thinker and
puppet master and if you recall the
discussion that we had previously had on
the Fantastic Four in a Fantastic Four
issue number 538 we had talked about how
the thinker and puppet master we're
villains that were really just kind of
using the current civil war to their
advantage to really kind of
implement their own schemes at the time
we didn't really know what that meant
but in this comic we will find out and
what we see as this comic begins to
unfold is that Captain America and his
team are really kind of going over and
sort of finalizing plans to intercept
Iron Man's convoy as he is transporting
the captured superheroes that we saw an
amazing spider-man issue number 534 to
an unclosed unenclosed destination a non
disclosed destination and so this is
really kind of interesting here because
this comic book takes place before the
events of amazing spider-man issue
number 534 and then really kind of
catches up and takes place alongside the
events of amazing spider-man issue
number 534 and what we see as Captain
America and his team are really kind of
sort of I guess laying plans out is a
really kind of trying to get things
finalized is that three members of the
Yancy Street gang appear to them and
tell them they know exactly the route
that that Iron Man is going to take they
know exactly where it is that he's going
to go and so we were previously Captain
America was concerned that their lack of
knowledge of which route he was going to
take was really going to kind of stretch
their numbers thin and the sense that
they would have to cover all the routes
now they have a pretty solid idea of
which way to go now the information is
kind of questioned by Captain America
that is to say he's really kind of
curious work came from and the Yancy
Street gang won't necessarily tell him
where it came from they'll just simply
tell him that it is a very reliable
source who is beyond contestation now
from here we switched to the thinker and
puppet master now the thing Korean
puppet master really interesting here
because the thinker and puppet master
are longtime enemies of the Fantastic
Four and while neither possesses any
superpower per se they are both really
kind of a very respectable in their own
right thinker is a genius-level
intellect he really is able to predict
the most logical of the most likely
outcomes in any given scenario using
mathematics to his advantage in addition
he is a very talented
I guess technological genius and really
kind of has a level of intelligence that
is on par with a Doctor Doom and Reed
Richards and individuals like that in
addition prop master again doesn't
necessarily have any powers but what he
does have is the ability to manipulate
this kind of magical clay
and whenever he makes clay models of
particular individuals he is able to
manipulate the actions of those
individuals and what we see is that they
have gone to the very tedious process of
making a very large-scale model of this
area this section of Manhattan where
they expect to have their plans really
kind of unfold and what we see is that
they've made some claim model decoys of
virtually everyone who is going to be
involved a multitude of individuals
including the Yancy Street gang here
we're going to be protesting a multitude
of individuals including the superheroes
now under normal circumstances
puppetmaster is not able to manipulate
the physical actions of superheroes but
due to a kind of headset that the
thinker has created for him he is now
going to be able to manipulate those
individuals in addition and what we
learn is that the information that was
revealed to Captain America on behalf of
the Yancy Street gang was actually given
to the Yancy Street gang by puppet
master and by the thinker so that they
could really kind of control all
variables in this equation from there we
switch to Ben Grimm and Ben Grimm's
really just kind of having lunch Jesus
really kind of enjoying himself and you
know there's some witty banter back and
forth between himself and the deli maker
or the deli owner but the daily owner
goes to business for us to inform him
that the Yancy Street gang intends to
protest iron man's convoy and actually
intends to create as much of a
disturbance as they can and this really
kind of concerns Ben Grimm because he
feels like the Yancy Street gang may
very well have been bitten off more than
they can chew they're really kind of
over their heads in this one and so from
here we switch to captain ramsoy to
spider-man and we really kind of pick up
with the events of spider-man issue
number 534 but this time we get more of
a perspective and where we saw that
spider-man's spider-sense began to go
off that he really kind of detected
Captain America and his team we see that
he's that the group is actually ambushed
by the Yancy Street gang and a multitude
of protesters and Ironman makes the
decision to go ahead and detour away
from these protesters and to head down
Route C which takes them to Yancy Street
and the the team the entire convoy is
really not necessarily ambushed by
individual individuals on this street
they're really just kind of verbally
abused they have things
their own and so on and so forth and
then we see puppet master and thinker
really kind of begin to get into the
fray and what we see is that puppet
master manipulates one of the jet
fighter pilots into firing missiles now
the missiles for the most part are
really kind of I guess intercepted by
Iron Man's team but then we see that Ben
Grimm arrives in the midst of all this
chaos and watches everything happen at
the same time that Captain America's
group appears while all this is going on
we see that mouth of the Yancy Street
gang who is under the influence of
puppet master goes to a trash candidate
to pick up a bomb that had previously
been laid there and under the influence
of puppet master his intention is to lay
the bomb out and kill as many people as
possible as many of the superheroes as
possible which will fulfill the goals of
the thinker and puppet masters so that
they will have as many superheroes out
of the way so that they can really kind
of begin their plans for conquest and so
on and so forth what we see is that Ben
Grimm is able to stop the bomb from
killing a large array of people by
throwing one of the convoy trucks on top
of it and then realizes that Maus is
under control of puppet master but then
we also see that he's distraught to see
that one of the members of the Yancy
Street gang a younger member of the gang
is killed in the explosion from here Ben
Grimm really just kind of freaks out and
he goes absolutely chaotic on Iron Man
and Captain America not in the sense
that he becomes physically violent but
in the sense that he just starts
screaming at them that this war that
they have caused the civil war that they
have started has really kind of torn the
superhero community in half but not only
that is cost the lives of people who
under normal circumstances would never
have been involved in this in the first
place and so he's really kind of asked
by both Captain America and Iron Man to
join their respective sides and Ben
Grimm declines both offers he says he
will not join either side he actually
goes as far as to say the hell with them
and that he's leaving the country he
doesn't even know if he's ever going to
be back again